welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus docker on this episode
of the podcast I talk with ajaya Katra
who's a senior research analyst at open
philanthropy in her role at open
philanthropy ajaya has produced what is
perhaps the most in-depth report on AI
development
AI is advancing rapidly but how much
will it change the world
we discuss how we can know whether the
pace of change is accelerating how to
think clearly in a fast-moving world and
how we should respond both personally
and professionally if we expect the
World to Change quickly in the future
here's ajaya Katra
okay
let's talk about a fast moving worlds
and how the future could arrive sooner
than we might think it it would so in my
terminology I have categorized your
thinking into kind of thinking in one in
on the one hand about the default
picture of the future and on the other
hand about the accelerating picture of
the future would you tell me about this
difference
yeah um I guess the default picture of
the future that many people imagine is
that you know eventually Humanity might
be a space-faring civilization we might
have cool technology like teleportation
Tech or uh you know mind uploading
technology or uh you know faster than
light travel or all these things
um you know if they're physically
possible we might have them
um but that this is like not really very
relevant to us and you know it might
happen in the year 3000 or the year five
thousand because you know
we need to
progress really far in science and
technology before we get to that state
and we're kind of progressing at like
some steady state now uh steady rate now
so the accelerating view of history and
the future
um roughly says that growth rates have
been accelerating over time since uh the
beginning of human civilization uh
basically because
as humans
invent some technology that improves
productivity that kind of increases the
carrying capacity of the world increases
the number of humans that can be
supported which means population
increases which means there are more
people who could come up with you know
incremental increases in productivity
um so if you map that out that model
suggests that if we don't see
exponential growth like X percent growth
per year we see super exponential growth
uh where you know maybe at the beginning
of time at the beginning of History we
were growing at point zero one percent
per year and that it's point zero two
percent per year and then it's you know
eventually it's 0.1 per year and then
one percent per year then uh two percent
per year and so on
so that suggests that you know a naive
extrapolation of that suggests that we
reach infinite productivity or infinite
growth and finite time
um and that that finite time period is
not that far away it's like 20 50 or
something now of course we don't get
infinite growth in finite time because
we hit various physical limits you know
if nothing else the limit of speed of
light to try and like
travel from Earth to other places that
have resources will cap our growth at
some point but the kind of
the adjusted conclusion would be there's
going to be a period of time before 2050
uh when growth is radically faster than
it is now before it levels off
um and then that kind of has the effect
that perspective kind of has the effect
of compressing the future it has the
effect of you know if you thought that
a thousand years of
human scientific progress would be
enough to get us to some crazy
post-singularity world where we're
space-faring civilization and so on
then if you believe we'll invent
technology that accelerates the pace of
that progress
um and then accelerates that in an
accelerating way then you kind of expect
all the science and progress and
research that might have been made over
those thousand years to be compressed
into five years or ten years and the
main technology we're talking about here
is AI which is what could compress all
of this scientific discovery into a
shorter period of time yeah
um and so
the accelerating world or the the
accelerating picture of the future is
one in which we make all the same
discoveries that you you would kind of
in the default picture think that we
would make in a thousand or ten thousand
years we make those same discoveries
maybe within 50 years and then we hit
these physical limits so so you're
thinking that we we are if we don't
destroy ourselves we will discover and
build technology to the edges of what's
physically possible
yeah and um I think that it the speed up
is even more dramatic than what you
described of 50 years the definition of
transformative AI
that we use in my timelines report and
elsewhere is AI systems that could 10x
the pace of progress
um
so
with 10xing the pace of progress that's
not a one-time boost so in particular
they also 10x the pace of AI progress so
they
they 10x they're like research that
would have been necessary to create even
more powerful systems that 100x the pace
of progress and those systems you know
are furiously inventing all sorts of
things including even more powerful
systems that can thousinex the pace of
progress and so on and they're going to
be some limits to that based on
some kind of unknown physical
um or otherwise constraints on how
quickly research could possibly be done
um but we shouldn't be imagining a
one-time boost of 10x which would mean
that you know something that takes a
thousand years would instead take a
hundred years uh we should kind of be
imagining
we often imagine the kind of like
characteristic thing as you know
the doubling time of
Innovation or growth or whatever is
one year and then it's six months and
then it's three months and then it's one
and a half months and then it's three
weeks and so on
um which is how you get the uh reaching
infinity and finite time effect of
extrapolating that
and we should say that there are some
papers in kind of mainstream economics
that ex just extrapolating past growth
Trends reaches this conclusion of
infinite growth in uh in the near future
so it's it's not just you saying this
it's uh it's it is the extrapolation
that that arises if you take into
account uh past growth rates
yeah my I don't totally know exactly
about the economic literature my
understanding is that this conclusion is
reached if we use
pretty standard models of how Innovation
Works like endogenous growth models and
fitting those models to historical data
tends to have this conclusion fall out
from that but I think
economists in general are pretty
skeptical of this overall
um
partly because it just sounds absurd and
I think partly because they tend to work
more with data from the last 100 years
as opposed to data from the last 10 000
years and they tend to be skeptical of
the quality of older data which is
totally fair and so
if you just look in the last 100 years
our growth actually looks roughly
constant and it's only when you
you know include the last 10 000 years
doesn't seem clear that
um our growth rate hasn't been constant
of time
um and so
often they'll take these models but
they'll set the parameters such that you
expect constant growth going forward but
in fact if you wiggled those parameters
a little bit it would suggest either
growth accelerating to infinity or
stagnation where like eventually uh GDP
stays constant isn't growing at all
um I think my understanding is
economists are much more likely than
people in the futurist crowd uh and
people at open field to believe that
growth will stay exponential for a long
time or else stagnate as opposed to
accelerating
okay what I would like us to do is to
talk about from the personal
epistemological and and psychological
position how do we how do we understand
which World we're closer to how do we
how do we find out whether we're closer
to the default world or the accelerating
world now just take a of this you know
um start with my own experience where
I'm I'm following the news about
artificial intelligence and it seems
like every month or even every week a
new amazing paper is coming out about
now we have this capability and we have
corrected
um the mistakes that uh all that we have
we have taken into account what the
critics are saying about the paper we
published last month and now we've
corrected those mistakes so how do we
handle this kind of flood of information
about progress and AI in a rational way
because it seems like we could we could
either get over hyped or we could get a
very panicked about progress and we want
to avoid both of those I think
as World we're in I'm not sure that AI
progress as we kind of subjectively
process it on the scale of weeks or
months is hugely informative for that I
think that
in the longer or medium term I would be
looking for
has the U.S economy
picked up is it growing slightly faster
as a result of AI or is it growing
slightly faster at all and particularly
can that be attributed to Ai and I don't
think that's really happened so far AI
systems have been very cool and the
research progress has been fast but it
hasn't it hasn't really translated into
a very large industry in terms of
dollars per year and hasn't added much
to world GDP yet
um I think it probably will start
adding and like I
you know if my views on timelines are
right I expect that 10 years from now
will have economists saying oh you know
this was like
surprisingly fast growth I don't think
we'll have economists saying you know
now it's the singularity like we believe
that there's going to be infinite growth
in finite time but more like oh we had
really modeled growth as being
two and a half percent but actually it's
more like three or three and a half
percent and it's been that way for a few
years so it's not a fluke
um it's not just recovery from something
um so that kind of sign feels like a
more durable uh sign of whether we're in
the accelerating world as well as kind
of observing specifically how AI how
useful AI is to scientists doing their
job how much people report that it
people in Innovation Fields specifically
report that it accelerates them and
looking at you know
in 10 years can Google do the same
amount of work that it did in 2022 with
half the workforce
um you know in 10 years is there a
factory that is similarly productive
with half the workforce so that kind of
like kind of big picture macro Trends is
what I'd be looking for and I don't know
if we have super strong evidence of that
in the next couple of years
um in terms of handling the flood of
information about AI in a healthy way I
don't know like I find it quite
stressful too
um
I think it's
it can create a sense of
chaos and a sense of you know you have
to run as fast as you can to stay in the
same place or you know a sense of trying
to outrun
something much larger than you
um and that can definitely be
very stressful and I'm not sure I have
great coping strategies I can offer
people right now
okay
um so if if we're thinking about we're
thinking about AI progress and you're
saying that we haven't seen massive
changes in economic growth as a result
of AI
and what about the the valuations of uh
companies that are that are heavily
invested in AI could they point us in
the direction could we use the market to
predict whether AI will be a big deal
very soon because then it seems like
maybe companies such as such as Google
or meta or Microsoft should have even
higher valuations if if the market as a
whole believed that we are approaching a
very fast progress in AI that will
change growth rates
yeah I think that looking at company
valuations and how they've changed is a
pretty good idea I haven't done that too
much yet I think it's like
at least
I'm not very well versed in finance but
my understanding is at least it's at
least somewhat non-obvious how you
translate a market cap into an
expectation of Revenue in the future
because you could maybe expect this to
have a modest amount of Revenue but for
a very long time or like a high revenue
for a shorter period of time or
something like that
um and then also some companies are not
as purely betting on AI I think that all
the big tech companies are kind of doing
a mix of AI and other more prosaic
things but I broadly does seem like the
market
these companies that have exposure to AI
have gone up over the last five years
probably will continue to go up uh
companies like Nvidia uh various
startups building AI uh like open AI
anthropic Adept you know a bunch of
other places like that and
um the the kind of larger tech companies
as well uh probably
their valuation will continue to climb
and that will
see an indication of people kind of
expecting
at least partly it'll be an indication
of people expecting AI driven
uh profit
but I think in general it's pretty safe
to say that the world is just not at all
prepared for uh being transformed by
artificial intelligence anytime soon
people have people are making plans that
relies on the world not changing that
much and not moving that fast so it
seems like that if we get this world of
um very fast growth driven by AI
then a lot of people will will have
their plans disrupted in in quite
uncomfortable ways uh perhaps and you
could imagine you could imagine the the
kind of
societal
chaos or disruption arising from very
fast uh very fast AI progress I'm
thinking not only of employment issues
or unemployment issues but also maybe in
a sense of a loss of meaning or a loss
of control for humans again I'm not I'm
not proposing that you'll be our
psychologist on this podcast but maybe
you I know you've spent a lot of time
thinking about this so maybe you have
something to
to help us deal with with this world
yeah um
so I have found
yelling of frenzy and panic when I
picture what my life might be like in 20
years uh right as AI systems are you
know making everything go crazy
um like faster growth like very intense
pressure cooker like environment
especially for somebody that wants to be
close to Ai and wants to help with it
and that is very stressful for me
um and it's been like pretty hard on my
mental health for the last couple of
years I think one of the things that
helps me
like
feel better about it is to remind myself
that
in some ways all of this chaos and
craziness is a consequence of
there being a hope for like a much
better future
most people imagine a world where
humans exist every human has a kind of
short life
um involving you know some joy and some
suffering
then they die and Humanity as a whole
will probably die off in a few thousand
years or a few tens of thousands of
years
um
but
what I'm picturing is something just
much higher stakes and weirder and
crazier where there's a real shot at
something
Grand and beautiful that is
much more than
I expected was possible for
you know sentient beings to have uh
there's a possibility of creating
you know a truly utopian future with
technology
and it's sort of as a result of that
possibility being real that there's
going to be this period of
you know chaos and stress
um and risk and we should try and reduce
that risk but I try and have a
perspective
I don't always succeed
um but I think that it's helpful to
frame it as
this whole package including the crazy
chaos and scariness and substantial risk
is a lot
brighter of a future than I thought we
were going to get before I thought about
all this
maybe you could elaborate on what you
mean by this utopian future
um what is it that that we could
arrive at if we succeed in uh surviving
this very high stakes situation of a
fast-moving world with a very powerful
AI
yeah I mean I at a sort of Baseline I
think
all of the good things you might have
expected from Science and Technology
like you know extending Health span
um and you know during cancer and like
uh eliminating infectious diseases
making everything cheaper like you know
making sure uh making everything so
cheap energy so cheap and food so cheap
that everyone in the world has access to
you know lots of great food inventing
really convincing meat Alternatives or
lab Meats uh so that we no longer do
factory farming just in general
technology has been
good overall in the history of humanity
for empowering humans reducing poverty
and suffering giving people choices
um and I think it this is more
controversial but I think it also has
a some kind of causal effect on
improving values I think people who are
more comfortable and secure and have
more of what they need
are often able to kind of more afford
the luxury goods of caring for people
who are very far away and wanting to do
altruistic pro-social things whereas if
you're in a very desperate situation you
kind of have less room for that in your
mind so I think both materially and
morally I think
technology has been very good and I
think if we
make it past this hurdle we'll have
much more quickly than
I thought we would in the past have all
those benefits and then I think it gets
crazier from there if you imagine one of
those Technologies being the ability to
upload people's brains onto computers so
mind uploads are digital people uh that
seems like it's something that's
physically possible it seems very hard
it seems like we're kind of nowhere near
getting to that point if you extrapolate
the progress of modern Neuroscience but
if you have AI systems that have done
the equivalent of many hundreds of
generations of Neuroscience research
then that might be possible very soon
and then if people are uploaded onto
computers I think and we have kind of
good rule of law around how
they can be treated
then
they're kind of Limitless possibilities
you don't really feel you're not
necessarily restricted to physics as we
know it
um you can just have like
you can choose exactly how you look uh
and you know you could fly or whatever
you wanted
um and I think that's kind of crazy
is there an argument to be made that
this creating this high-stakes situation
for the world and I'm not blaming any
particular company or individual for
this but just the overall state of of
competition between technology companies
creating this potentially high-stakes
situation is is that in some sense
immoral if you're if you imagine a
person who began thinking that
um technical technological progress was
a bit too fast in the
1800s and and they joined the Amish and
this person's children are now kind of
have stepped outside of technological
progress should should is it important
that such people be allowed to live
their lives in the in what we could call
the default world
should it so because there's a sense in
which it's not possible to get off the
ride of technological progress if you're
in this world and you are
um people who want to get off the ride
are left without any form of agency
because progress is being driven by Yeah
by this by this kind of system of
companies and people uh competing with
each other interacting with each other
and and and driving a very high pace of
the future
so
to answer the first question I don't
think that it's on that immoral too
participate in technological progress I
think right now ai progress in
particular I would prefer that it went
slower but I think this is a pretty
complicated argument and I don't think
it's helpful to frame people that
disagree with me about a complicated
argument or haven't thought about a
complicated argument
um as doing something immoral
um
the second question of
should we or could we have people choose
to kind of opt out on a personal level
um
in terms of technological possibility I
think it will be more possible than it
was in the past to create a sort of like
Amish Earth
um or leave behind
physical normal Earth and have digital
people live elsewhere and so on
um in terms of political negotiation
around that that's much more complicated
but it seems pretty plausible to me that
a lot of people will have demand for
getting to choose and meter how crazy
their life is
um and I think it will be less Fringe of
a position than the Amish position is uh
today because it'll be much more
scary and like totally transformative to
embrace all these technological changes
right away
so I think that we will probably end up
observing
degrees of
like adoption of these Technologies
based on what people feel comfortable
with and they'll probably be a number of
people that
don't want to become a digital person uh
don't want to be
very long living even as a biological
person want to have a life that's more
like
you know a particularly wealthy person
in a wealthy country today
um that's pretty normal and that it
would be possible to like make that
happen for them
yeah of course it's it's difficult to
speculate about these things but I could
also easily imagine a movement of people
who are you know buying a house in the
countryside living more traditionally
and and kind of opting out of of
technological progress as far as that's
possible we're talking now about quite
kind of we're trying to imagine a very
concrete future so when we're trying to
imagine how the future might be should
we ought to be more concrete or should
we be more vague because it it seems
that if if we're vague in the sense that
for example we talked about economic
growth rates you could leave it
unspecified what would be causing this
massive rise in growth and then it's
it's uh statistically more likely that
you're right because you haven't
specified an exact scenario on the other
hand it seems more useful if you then
specify that oh it's it's a artificial
intelligence that's driving this uh this
rise in growth so how do you think about
uh concreteness versus bakeness in
imagining possible futures
to have
trim of these
explored
um and kind of go back and forth between
I think I wouldn't want to frame it as
vague I think like truly vague
speculation of the future about the
future is
like generally not that useful in the
sense of just kind of being like Oh the
future like will probably be crazy but
um I would say maybe like model driven
um so if you were to draw a chart of
economic growth
um
throughout history and extrapolate that
forward and say somehow I think we are
our default guest should be that growth
will look like this extrapolation that
is not vague in the sense that you have
something to work with but it is
abstract
um in the sense that you're not telling
a story uh and I think
we should generally be
expecting and aiming for
these different lines of evidence and
thought to be pointing in the same
direction and be curious when they're
not
um and try and reconcile them when they
don't and try and think about can I
bring in some other perspective that
tells me which of these perspectives is
wrong
but yeah I think I would not feel very
good if I had
no models
um that suggested
this was possible in a broad sense and I
also wouldn't be feeling very good if I
couldn't imagine any particular way this
could happen
um and I think it's kind of like
these different things are useful for
different purposes I think the like more
abstract uh
models are probably more useful for
having
General beliefs and for making forecasts
about the long-term future and I think
more concrete stories are often more
useful for
making particular plans and for sanity
checking models
um because you often can't
really
act on something that's like the world
might go crazy and growth might be
really fast in the next 30 Years
what I had in mind when asking this
question was books such as the economist
Robin Hansen's h of M or recurs Files
The Singularity is near where they they
paint very precise pictures that that
can then also be very precisely wrong
[Music]
but so is is worth spending more time on
such on projects like that or is it is
it better to spend time in you could you
could call it a model thinking or more
um uh broad thinking
um
I mean I think that both are pretty
underdone
um this particular level of specificity
of
of age of M and the singularity is near
I think
I am like somewhat more skeptical of
that sort of thing which is
which is to say they kind of
they're not very qualified they kind of
act as if all these things are
um obvious they have statements like age
of M has a bunch of claims about things
like you know how quickly do factories
reproduce themselves and he makes a
statement that this is one month but
there's no citation or analysis there
um and it's covering like every single
aspect of society it's trying to tell a
concrete
story about
you know everything and it's trying to
it's it's not particularly careful about
what's more uncertain what the different
possibilities are
um and it's not particularly
careful about analyzing some of these
quantitative parameters that go into the
story and that I think is somewhat less
useful
um I think
concrete stories are often
more useful when there's one kind of
high level thing that you think is
probably going to happen like misaligned
AI systems you know pose a significant
danger and you want to kind of lay out a
way or ideally multiple ways that that
thing could happen it feels somewhat
more useful to me and often you have an
intuition that that kind of thing will
happen because of a pretty abstract
argument and this is more kind of
lending support to the abstract argument
and trying to see if making it more
concrete reveals that it's lot or not
right in somewhere
if we discover that we are in this
accelerating world how should we change
our plans uh what should we do
differently
personally or professionally
both I'm thinking about
I mean professionally
more people should seriously consider
learning about these Technologies
if they can be helpful in some way with
this transition especially people who
are already committed to
using their careers too do something
good for the world it seems like a
neglected opportunity to do something
good for the world
um and you can have an outsized
influence if you are relatively early to
being concerned about it
um and you believe that in the future
lots more people will be concerned
personally I think
it's more complicated I think um
people are relatively risk-averse so you
know
I know some people who aren't saving for
retirement because they expect that
you know very powerful AI will be built
um pretty soon
and like you know they'll
that won't be like
they're not planning to be 70.
um I think that
for most people even if you have a
pretty high probability on that
um even something like a 20 probability
on this being wrong and you actually
living to 70 in a normal world and like
wishing you would save for retirement
probably motivate some amount of saving
for retirement
um so I think you probably have to have
uh either unusual confidence or unusual
like Risk neutrality in order to like
sort of totally change around your
financial planning based on this
um
I know some people who are investing in
AI companies because they believe that
AI is undervalued uh based on their
views about how soon that it's likely to
have transformative impacts
um and that would be
one way to attempt to beat the market
and
uh make more money but it's definitely
very volatile and you know just recently
Tech crashed a bunch
um and so you know it kind of depends on
your personality and your financial
circumstances whether it really has any
implications on that front
any other things just kind of like
I think it's just a big thing to
grapple with and think about like in
terms of whatever amount of your time
you spend thinking about
like life and the nature of the world
um it's just a pretty big
thing that is I think probably gonna
happen uh and it's pretty scary and wild
uh and
you know I think may have
subtle idiosyncratic effects on people's
how they conduct their lives in the same
way that
you know there's a cliche that getting a
diagnosis of cancer does for some people
um it might be a wake-up call to
prioritize differently whatever that
means for people
um
but yeah that's
gonna be very person specific and
you know for a lot of people I think it
shouldn't necessarily change too much in
their personal lives
say that we meet again in
2070 and it's the case that we now have
self-driving cars and we have uh better
virtual reality uh technology and better
medicine but nothing radical has
happened we we were it turned out we
were more in the default World versus
the accelerating world
what would be your best guess as to how
um your picture of the of the world was
wrong in that scenario
yeah I think it would be probably
something like we are at about how
useful ml systems will be and it turns
out that it was too hard to train them
to do like truly autonomous powerful
economically valuable tasks
um you know maybe they were too brittle
and we could never get their rates of
dumb errors down uh enough or maybe
automating that kind of task
would have been possible to require far
more computation than we actually had
available or far more data than we had
available and then as a result of AI
progress kind of stalling out
um investment and research and stuff
stalls out too and there's kind of
another AI winter where people aren't
really thinking much about AI
um and it's not a particularly
fast-paced or lucrative field to be in
um and then that lasted
quite a while that seems like plausible
to me that that's how things will end up
I definitely don't have
you know strong confidence that we will
that that won't be the case I think I
have like at least
20 chance that that happens maybe more
like 30 percent chance
it is there is a certain danger to
extrapolating Trends so if we could
imagine the epistemic situation of a
person looking at birth rates in 19 late
50s and seeing them just Spike and
thinking about whether the world will be
overpopulated in the year 2000 or 2050
or we could imagine if we could imagine
after the moon landing we might think
that in the year 2000 we will definitely
have a moon colony and maybe in two in
2050 we will have a Mars colony and so
on and so what's the risk that this
could be happening in your
extrapolations that that you're basing
your beliefs on certain Trends moving in
a in a particular way but these trends
for various uh natural or physical
limits they slope off and what looked to
be exponential uh turned out to to to be
more like an s-curve
I agree that that like
there's only so much you can get from
extrapolating Trends it's a very
you know low information thing in the
end even though I think it's often the
best we have I think it's like kind of
tough for me to answer specifically what
the chance is that that's off
um I think you know you can always pick
times when
there are a bunch of examples of times
when Trend extrapolation leads people
astray but I nonetheless think that
as a strategy it would have done better
than like many other strategies
especially ones that are kind of driven
by people's intuitions about what's
absurd or like what's possible
um and so I think it's kind of like
you know it's it's an inherently
difficult
thing to try and estimate the future
we're probably very wrong by default uh
and so you know probably what I have in
mind is wrong
um but yet I don't really think that I
have a particular reason to deviate in a
particular way from
Trend extrapolation because I think
Trend extrapolation can also
underestimate progress
um and it's not only the case the trend
extrapolation overestimates progress
it definitely goes both ways so the
trends I just mentioned were
specifically Cherry Picked by me to show
this phenomena of the of the sloping off
effect and you could I could have picked
economic growth that so far has can has
continued uh to to accelerate
um
but
yeah I'm thinking like
um
if we return to the to the current
models I know you you said that we
shouldn't put too much emphasis on the
language and image models that we're
seeing right now and I agree with that
but given that we haven't seen massive
economic impact yet that's the current
uh the current set of models seems to me
to be the way or the place to begin
speculating about what will happen the
the I'm thinking that these models are
the place from which we begin thinking
about Which models we will have the in
the future that will have significant
economic impact so
shouldn't we put at least a decent
emphasis on on the current models
yeah so specifically the thing I said
was that um
I don't think looking at week to week or
month-to-month progress in existing
models gives a huge amount of evidence
of whether we're in the world where
we're about to cap out and reach an AI
winter or we're in the accelerating
World
um I do think thinking about existing
models is very important for other
reasons
um and you know my report on uh
the plausibility of AI takeover relies
on kind of imagining a path to
transformative AI That's uh
very like close descendant of existing
models and I think a lot about existing
models to kind of
try and have one concrete picture to
test my
theories against
um and I also think that it's very it's
actually pretty plausible that
transformative AI arrives in you know
just several years from now and
in that case I think it is plausible
that it looks very similar to existing
systems and you could argue that
people who want to influence the future
of AI have the most leverage on these
unusually short timelines which I think
have less than 50 probability because
they might be unusually risky um so it
might be unusually important to reduce
Risk by some amount relative some amount
relative to the total
um and
they might be easiest to intervene on
specifically because we can get further
by imagining these systems being very
similar to existing systems so our
research is better targeted to them
versus something that arrives in 30
years
if we're in a very very fast moving
world where a transformative AI arrives
say within 10 years
how is what we should do different from
what we should do if it's more likely to
arrive within 30 years or say a hundred
years so what I'm thinking about here
this is very difficult question to
answer of course but how should we train
change our priorities based on our best
guess about how fast moving the world
we're in actually is
yeah so I think within AI safety in
particular
um and
all the activities that are focused on
AI directly I think it's actually makes
a surprisingly small difference to
prioritization uh mainly because
if we think that AI is going to arrive
in 30 years
we're kind of stuck just imagining it
being like pretty similar to today's
systems because it's probably going to
be different but we don't really know
how it's going to be different
um and so if our probability on 30 years
versus 10 years changes
um I think that
the tools we use for like thinking about
things are not going to change as much
um
and then the other reason is
it's probably productive to just work on
the next problem you might face first so
you know even if you have if you had a
five percent chance that it was in 10
years or 10 chance or 15 chance as long
as it's a significant chance I think
it's like productive in terms of
feedback loops to
focus on those worlds and then if you're
wrong focus on the next 10 years and
then if you're wrong focus on the next
10 years because you're more likely to
be able to do productive work like close
up toward when transformative AI is
developed because you have a better
picture of everything at that time
in terms of like the balance between AI
work and other work I think there's more
of a change there where as our timelines
are longer uh we
probably want to shift more resources
toward uh community building and saving
versus
um spending our resources on AI right
now
um but I think that's more relevant for
someone in a philanthropist position
kind of trying to decide how to allocate
fungible resources than it is from the
perspective of someone who's deciding on
their career where I think from the
perspective of someone who's deciding on
their career
for a pretty wide range of timelines
fluctuations you probably want to decide
whether you're going to be doing AI or
not AI based on your personal interests
and skills as opposed to these kinds of
considerations because it's actually
fairly rare for somebody to have
a close enough fit for these two things
that the difference is made by thinking
about time lapse
that's yeah thank you for doing this
interview with me it was very
informative thank you